what i want to do in this video is
understand two words that you might hear
associated with
parabolas and that is
that is a focus
that is a focus of a parabola
focus
and a directrix
directrix
directrix right over there so what are
these things well a parabola can be
defined as the set of all points let me
draw an arbitrary
axis right over here so that's my
y-axis
this is my x-axis
and so a parabola can be defined as the
set of all points that are equidistant
to a point
and a line and that point is the focus
of that parabola and that line is the
directrix of the parabola so what am i
talking about so let's give ourselves a
point so let's say this point
right over here and we could even say
that that is the point let's say that's
the point let's say the x coordinate is
a
and the y coordinate is b right over
here so that is the point a
comma b and then let's give ourselves a
line for the directrix and actually let
me do this in a different color instead
of just white because i already did the
coordinates in white so i will do it in
this magenta color
so that's a comma b is the focus and
let's say
y equals c is the directrix so this
right over here is the line
this right over here is the line y is
equal to c
so this on the y axis right over there
that is c
this is the line y is equal to c
so a parabola what does it mean to be
the set of all points that are
equidistant between a point and this
line
let's think about what those points
might be well this point right over here
would be halfway
between
between this point between the focus and
the directrix and then as we move away
from x equals a you're going to get
points
anywhere along this curve
which is
a parabola and you might be saying wait
i don't i don't get this i don't get why
points along
this curve are going to be equidistant
well let's let's just eyeball the
distances
so this one this distance and obviously
i'm drawing it by hand so it's not going
to be completely precise that distance
needs to be equal to that distance well
that seems believable
and now this if we take this point right
over here on the parabola this distance
needs to be the same as that distance
well that seems believable if you take
this point on the parabola
this distance
this distance needs to be the same as
this distance so hopefully you get what
i'm talking about when i say that the
parabola is all as a set of all points
that are equidistant to this focus and
this directrix so any point along this
parabola this point right over here this
point right over here the distance to
the focus
the distance to the focus
should be the same as the distance
as the distance
to the directrix now what you might
realize is when you're taking the
distance between a point and a point you
could the distance can
it'll be at a i guess you could say it
could be at an angle this one's straight
up and down this one is going from the
top left to the bottom right when you
take the distance from a point to a line
you essentially drop a perpendicular you
essentially go straight down or if the
parabola was down here you would go
straight up to find that distance these
are all these are all right angles right
over here so that's all a focus and a
directrix is and every parabola
is going to have a focus and directrix
because every parabola is the set of all
points that are equidistant to some
focus and some directrix so that's what
they are in future videos we'll try to
we'll try to think about how do you
relate these points the focus and the
directrix to the actual to the actual
equation or the actual equation for a
parabola